are there any any absences
yes Chad we received apologies from
Council of Western uh councilor
chabrowski and councilor Acton
I can feel Declarations of Interest
many members
thank you
I could three minutes of the the last
meeting if any points anybody wants to
raise
can we agree as a true record of the
last meeting with
just section seven chair needs a bit of
a rewrite so I think we'll do that
offline and then circulate the final
draft if that's okay
section seven the
thank you
can that be agreed
service updates
this folder
[Music]
okay
um
program
can everybody hear them
um
hello can everybody hear me okay oh yeah
yeah I'm Claire Fraser I'm the head of
operations for tractors the inpatient
services at moorside and the outpatient
services
talk to you about our services and our
present quality picture so we provided
some stories from Lucy because everybody
have access to those surroundings are
great uh we're not going to go through
the basis
um but we did want to pick up on some
key issues and in particular focusing
our approval plan and quality
improvements and our services in
Trafford
so just uh summarizing the first few
slides uh between the slide pack for
background information provided Services
here in traffic they are mostly Adult
Services
um such as talking Therapy Services they
are previously known as I act services
will provide Community Mental Health
Services and inpatient mental health
services also Addiction Services and we
have some services that a couple people
can access that provides outside of
Trafford as well such as liaison
services that operate inside of AE
departments Crossroads Manchester
um we don't provide child adolescent
Mental Health Services here in Trafford
we've worked really closely with our
vcse partners as well to provide our
services and bcse partners and other NHS
Services also Finance power services
and we're here today because
we've had significant quality challenges
particularly over the last 12 to 18
moments coming out to covid and the
lockdown
you'll be aware that we've undertaken a
number of reviews ourselves as a trust
is included but importantly we just
wanted to mention we have two of those
this is still ongoing we have a national
external review that is underway and we
understood was due to conclude Billy
Autumn and there's also an ongoing
police investigation specifically into
the incidents that happened at Edinburgh
that also hasn't concluded we just
wanted to make sure the committee as
well
[Music]
we're very aware of the scared of the
challenges that the trust is facing
we are doing our workplace with group
we're very committed to improve or
whether through some of the improvements
that we are we've either made or we're
making
um anything further that does come out
of the uh two outstanding reviews will
be incorporated into our approval plan
an improvement plan at the moment
captures everything that anybody has
asked us to improve on
um we're also continuing with business
as usual Services too and we've talked
to Elizabeth with our day-to-day traffic
Services
um what we're doing is being fully
scrutinized by HS England
um we're in a
performance framework that's got an
Insight of our Improvement and of course
what we're doing for the time when NHS
services are pro challenged as well
anyway
um so we'll talk through some of that
and obviously we're very opposite
questions which I'm sure you'll have
problems
so I shall hand you over to Charlotte
who's going to talk to you about our
Improvement plan
thanks Liz can everybody hear me
um so as you'll see in the pack and
we've been giving you a high level
overview of the trustwide Improvement
plan this has been a plan that's been
developing over time since
um prior to the care and treatment
concerns that even filled and address
broader issues as Liz has mentioned
you'll recognize a significant scale and
Escape of the plan we
've Focus resources and expertise on
immediate policy and safety concerns
which Maria will come on to shortly the
plan was agreed although it is still
iterative as as Liz referred to most
recently changes based on the new CQC
report that was published in July I've
obviously taking account of a welcoming
recommendations that will be made and
will be folded into that plan we've got
five priority work streams and within
there this this sub kind of priorities
and each work students got a dedicated
executive lead as as Liz mentioned that
one is overseen and was scrutinized in
the delivery
um by nhse NHS England's national
college national teams our regional
colleagues and the trust has got
significant support that's been brought
in which is the NHS Improvement
intensive support team so we have our
own Improvement director and a team of
nhse colleagues who come and work with
us on the program in terms of supporting
and delivery
um as you'll imagine with any big
program there are a number of risks that
have been identified by the trust and
mitigation that's put in place uh the
risks do reflect a lot of those
those many NHS organizations and we will
continue to work to mitigate those uh as
we as we work through delivery
I'll just pass over to Maria to who will
give us a focus on some of the work
we've been doing about policy and safety
thank you
can you hear me
and okay and so there's quite a bit as
you can see it's an extensive um
Improvement plan
um my area particularly focus is on a
number of areas in terms of the
Improvement plan it's predominantly
allowed and patient safety I'm looking
at the patient's safety concerns that
have been raised by our cgc inspections
but also basically other inspections and
the pay or the slides that you've got
gives a breakdown on some of those
achievements but I just want to mention
a few areas that we're focusing on I've
had to focus on we've had a number of
29a requirement nurses by the CPC so we
really focused on what was they've
completed the date of the significant
Improvement was the 31st of August so
those areas were particularly working on
safety Staffing and fire safety
literature adoption and that leadership
adoption program is very much about the
environment but also around the practice
um policy and training for staff and
also a small conversation and that's a
big piece of work in terms of looking at
the policy practice training not just
for a staff but all to support our
patients in terms of smoking cessation
so to support each of those particular
areas and there has been additional
resources and attached to each of those
work streams and there is an extensive
action plan
and then there's also a system of
actually measuring Improvement in terms
of the practice at Ward level and at
patient level and that then is
translated into developing systems of
assurance that we would report into our
policy committee that oversees our
Improvement as part of the patient
safety work stream
and the other big pieces of work that
we're doing is looking at reducing
restricted practice and that's a
collaborative equality Improvement
collaborative as part of the national
program so that's looking at making sure
there are environments are more
therapeutic that they're at least
restrictive and they're looking at areas
such as meaningful activities and awards
reducing with strange reducing funds and
aggression and that will be a two-year
program and we'll be doing that along
with the National Elite in health which
are nhse
um safeguarding is also a key area for
improvement we've invested in our state
value teams and our governments around
and safeguarding and that will continue
um
the other area I want to I did mention
smokers safe smoking station is probably
our most challenged area
um and that's an area that we have to
continue to work on I think beyond the
warning notices and really I think it
would be fair to say that a during the
pandemic I think the policy across much
of the country has lived and other areas
that we look at of course as well
medicines management and Medicine safety
care planning and making sure that care
planning and risk assessments with
service users is person-centered so
there's a piece of work that we're doing
around the factors and again with the
policy
those are in terms of patient safety in
terms of safer Staffing we have
developed a whole program of making sure
that our staffing is safe on a shift
shift by shift basis and and I'm sure
those of you that have read the CTC
reports will recognize why that was
important and not only are we doing that
we also do
um very open and transparent reports to
our board so we have a system of
reporting from board to board on our
safer Staffing
um on a day and shift pressure faces and
that will continue and indefinitely and
as part of that work in looking at the
establishments so um in terms of the
number of staff that you've got as part
of the Award Team we've also started a
process of reviewing all our
establishments across all Awards and
we've had we're doing that work with the
support of the national team and looking
at and triangulating that work from a
two left in space to professional
judgment and the data that we have in
the organization
um so we're about to start in the next
few months and producing those reports
that will go to our board that will be
making recommendations about the future
establishments in terms of Staffing and
that's both registered and
non-registered staff on our boards
the other area for
um that we have been particularly
focusing on has been around nurse
leadership and and you know the CQC
found that there was gaps in terms of
our nurse leadership so we have been
investing in making sure that we have
nursing and quality roles from law to
board and that policy is very much
um a focused
a focus of everything that we do within
the organization so there's been
significant investment in heads of
nursing equality policy mentions and
also leadership roles and for example we
are having a new associate director for
safeguarding almost that will really
help us in terms of taking forward and
policy and Improvement
a key enabler for us to achieve what we
need to achieve in terms of the
Improvement plan is a recruitment and a
retention program and
um we are have a number of uh work
streams and projects to look at strength
from that and for example the use of
e-rounding and development of uh
temporary staffing team and also looking
at how we recruit people close to the
local communities so looking at moving
away from recruiting people from a
central Central Point to actually
enabling teams to recruit your for
example
wherever Manchester wherever that may be
and making sure that we're recruiting
people from local communities as we feel
that's that's an important step forward
for us and and that's also supplemented
with an international recruited
registered nurses as well
each of those areas are supported with a
word string an action plan but also
educational and development for staff
which has to be whole scale in terms of
the areas that I've mentioned to make
sure that the um the improvements that
we make here and now are sustained the
long term and that's that that will I
suppose need to continue much longer
than
um this this is a two-year program and
we need to make sure that they're
sustainable for the coming years
um I'm gonna stop there
yeah okay thank you so I'd just like you
to take you through
um the most recent CQC inspection
relating to uh Greenway Ward which is at
more side and just to give you a little
bit of background around that
it also incorporates
um the uh Woodlands hospital as well
which is a which is a hospital in little
haunton mentioned it here because some
of our Trafford residents
are are cared for at Woodlands as well
so the security inspected woodlands in
November 2022 and issued a regulation
29a warning notice and the service was
um
was inadequate subsequently in April
2023 uh the CQC visited Woodlands again
and along with that visited Greenway
award which is our 10 bedded older
adults organic Ward at broadside
so they found a Greenway we had good
lines of sights in terms of the position
of the the nursing office in relation to
visibility of patients on the board
we're complying with the same sex
guidance
there were some issues around the nurse
call and bell and where that was
situated and that's the part of the bird
trustwise piece of work around the nurse
call better cross for trust
and they did notice the recent
refurbishments the million pound
refurbishment has taken place at
Northside and it was cleaned and tidy
some of the area is noted for
improvements were around reducing the
vacancy rates and turnover rates and
five languages
as Marie has just mentioned we are
involved in the impulse review of award
establishments and across north side we
have uh we did take a measure a while
ago to increase the numbers of nursing
staff and nursing assistants that we
have to earn on board
third role in terms of the inpatient
boards we have improved the mandatory
training and and whether it's receive a
compound we've raised the service from
uh required from out of its requires
improvements and unsatisfied that
reactions from the 29a have been retired
and completed
so I just wanted to take a moment to uh
to talk through some of gmh's priorities
in terms of the Mental Health Integrated
partnership so across GM have five
Mental Health Mission areas around
supporting the communities engaging in
the neighborhoods having timely access
to support our residents and our service
users of living longer and reducing the
stigma and tackling the inequalities
that we show oftentimes with clinical
health
mental health is a cross-cutting theme
and across the across the Partnerships
and for the gmh um our priority is to
enable this to happen is to increase the
numbers of people accessing eye out it's
now called talking therapies that you
might might recognize it as I am to 25
prevalence and that's a national
um Target that we are
um aiming for the company funding is
23.1 percent
we want to eliminate mental health
placements out of area
and to do this we're working very
closely we've got very good
relationships with our partners with our
system partners and we're working very
closely with them to reduce those people
out of barriers and endure to work
towards discharging people who are in
the discharge
and fourthly we were working to deliver
on the community transformation which
again is a national piece of work and
collaborating and co-producing the
community services with the bcse local
partners
so as Marie has mentioned there's been a
lot of a lot of work happening and we've
made a significant progress in in lots
of areas so just to talk you through
some of those some of those areas
in terms of the um the achievements um
the progressing relating to the
Improvement plan
um with
um
trustwise rolled out the uh the new
document for the ligatures so in terms
of
um more up-to-date
um training for the staff including heat
maps for the staff on areas that are
ligature Focus
and we've done quite a lot of work in
relation to Fire and smoking cessation
on the unit and it is um it is one of
the challenges for us
um and we've been quite lucky in traffic
to have the smoking citation
um
work after leads to be present on the
units who provides a vegetable education
for the staff and the service users to
help them to engage in our in no smoking
um in our no smoking plan and the
availability of nrt products to help us
enormously along with that as well
we've expanded
um the the living well so this working
with the bcse and into the neighborhoods
and along with that the development of
um Pathways in the community so our
um complex emotional relational needs
pathway our co-occurring conditions
pathway working closely with cheese and
our partners around that and increasing
the number of psychological modalities
that are available to our residents as
well
in terms of our Workforce we
we've increased the number of Staff as
I've said on the board and we've been
successful in recruiting number of
qualified nurses to the inpatient unit
which um which we're delighted to come
on board in October today we've just
appointed we've got some funding and
we've just appointed a psychologist for
the inpatient unit so that's really
great news and our quality matron one of
the new roles that has just been
mentioned and starts at the end of the
month as well
we've also tried to implement on the
boards
and the the the triumphant model that
we've got across gmh as well with a with
a clinical lead and the operational
needs and our medical colleagues
um we're focusing on well-being on
well-being program for staff and
developing our our brand new nurses
having
um
lots of CPD for them and really
investing in our nursing staff
a very strong relationships with our
with our partners and I think that's a
real strength in in Trafford
um with the ICB with the Urgent Care
board with our stakeholders
and in terms of urgent and Emergency
Care we've
um
um we've developed with blue sky our
bcse partner the crisis Cafe and that's
going from strength to strength and
there's got some really really good
feedback this can we've got care
Navigators mainly and the MH the mental
health joint response vehicle
in terms of some challenges on the
opportunities
and some of the challenges for Trafford
has been that historical level
um of investment in Services
um which we're working to
um to level up really with the uh with
the mojos review establishments
we're seeing increasing demand and
Acuity and that's reflected in some of
the waiting uh times that we have that
you know we're having in some services
that we arrive
some of the workforce demands that we
know that are present nationally and the
the blog that we have in terms of
discharges from our acute inpatient unit
so talking Therapies
the Trafford is an example one and GM
talking therapist it's consistently high
performance
um and consistently meeting the rtt at
both 6 and 18 weeks the challenge for IX
is to improve the the weight between the
first and the second appointments and
consider growing
um consider growing the demand for
counseling
achieved also um has services in
Trafford for working with probation and
prison
to have that continued continuity of
care from people released
the well embedded in the community books
on the Living Well Service we have an
event in the end of September with our
partners around that co-oper and
conditioning pathway and they've
introduction they've introduced the harm
reduction team working on naloxone
distribution and working towards
reducing drug related deaths
thank you
um I suppose just to conceptualize the
opportunities and challenges that are
faced in Trafford
um many of which are replicated across
the trust and the ICB to varying degrees
and so I won't read them out for Basin
but um we're working closely with
commissioning colleagues and place-based
leads and other providers within the
locality to address and work on the
challenges and you know build on the
opportunities so we've got some great
opportunities about developing and
redesigning services and much of the
work that Maria and Claire have worked
on and as mentioned and importantly
investment that's coming through from
the ICB and also to my end-to-head
investment from ourselves in terms of
delivering Global Services but the
improvements that are required across
the organization I think one of the
really key bits that we recognize is
those positive relationships with vcse
colleagues in the locality and and also
the support that NHS England are
bringing us across the whole
organization to look at good practice
and learning from other areas and some
of those expertise and there are some
specific challenges across the trust and
GM around funding of some ongoing
services and some schemes that supports
through winter and through those demands
but we're working with our colleagues to
see how those can be addressed
thank you
thank you so um we just hope that
introduce you some information that's
useful
um very happy to take any questions that
you have but also just to say we are
very committed to making the Improvement
you've heard something for the work that
we've done it's working progress
um but we're Focus to to making those
approvements and to continue working
with all our hearts
are there any questions
and congratulations
as well and in particular a trust vision
and Trust values
um obviously with things that are
ongoing and reports that come out
it just seems to be like disconnect
May yes understand maybe it start stress
for the rest of the NHS is having the
same problem and we don't see stories
like that appearing or across the NHS
how are you going within your course
program
yeah probably use
and that trust Vision embedded into
every member of your team every member
staff are across
thank you
um it's a really good question we do
have a vision it's about improving lives
and working for people to create
optimistic features we think that's just
as valid now as it was three five years
ago and we do have values that which
were co-created with stuff so everybody
who's recruited is recruited in line
with the values
um and our staff have been really
pressurized through covert
um and also with the additional demand
for services we're asking people to do
more and more the whole of the NHS
including ourselves have a lot of focus
of rest and lots of our staff so a big
focus on well-being the staff we want to
support staff we want to recruit more
staffers very Cloud we're talking about
as well because we think that will help
staff in their roles and I guess we've
got we do have a strategy
um that strategy we think again is still
as valid that the actions that we're
delivering have to be absolutely the
improval plan that Maria's outbound uh
Maria is there anything else you wanted
to add to us in terms of values
I think one of the key pieces of work in
there is our cultural piece of project
that we're going to be driving forward
yeah obviously we've done a lot of
diagnostic work over the past
um 12 18 well 12 months specifically but
um we're now moving into that phase of
implementation of our new control piece
from a strategy perspective and that
will link in it goes into all staff will
[Music]
do you feel that there will be a refresh
along with all the new stuff
alongside the old stuff just to refresh
yourself
that's that's my real percentage my one
pushed forward is actually
to move forward together as a meeting
absolutely we've got a lot to do and I
guess we're trying to make some of the
basic safety improvements and then bring
everybody together while supporting
staff through Veterans are you
absolutely right is it cool well as the
NHS is probably what we stand for isn't
it
um so yes we will be working with stuff
on values and also we will be developing
a new vision with staff but we just want
to get some of the improved with London
first
thank you councilman
thank you
and I'd like to know more about your
poverty matron
please
um
job description the personal
specification what our actual role is
going to be and gavish is going to be
something to do with the
viewer obvious
ly
okay the quality management award has
been around for a while
um and really it's a focus on making
sure that there's somebody with any more
clinical team that's focused on policy
quality improvement uh the role would be
senior towards manager and unusual
cultivation will have more than one word
and things that they would do are things
like cleaning supervision and overseeing
Recruitment and the values of in terms
of equipment but also
um initiating
um some checks from some basic stuff and
like checking that as the quality checks
and rewards have done put in place by
cleanings information control
um person-centered care care planning
Mis assessment that those quality
um initiatives and and bread and butter
for mental health has actually been
complete to the standard that it needs
to be completed they would then would
report up
um to the next in our case will be ahead
of national policy and they're aligning
to me so I would expect and that the
quality of Majors will be doing reports
that outline the work that they're doing
in collaboration with the with the
reward managers in terms of driving of
that Improvement in practice and quality
they also have a role in terms of
patient experience so I would expect
that they'll be doing
um listening events with service users
and carers around their perception of
the quality care that they're receiving
so it's very much focused on that policy
and and while the war manager has a role
in that they also have operations manage
the The Ward and so this following is an
addition
um
and I just ask what the qualification
would be if that person so that person
has to then experience which is the
nurse and more often they have already
been a work manager themselves so they
have experience in terms of poverty
nursing and nursing practice and and
management
um nursing management
yes I've got three questions actually
um firstly I went on so I'm impressive
what you're doing in terms of
independental Health crisis isn't it
we've got so much in resources and I'm
aware that the French intervention is
crucial but so many of these issues are
kind of out of their control are due to
Lifestyle like deprivation abuse all
these other factors that you've got no
control over
um so I wondered how what how the
service were providing how pre does that
the image
I don't know I don't really know how to
explain to improve our poetry life is
obviously potential because people
stress out to work for example they're
going to get mental health issues so how
do you you know it's like where do you
where are you coming from when you're
when you're looking at this in terms of
that prevention for example
um I I was listening to probably about
how many calories
are disappeared young people are not
that are not supportive and that's
another reason for the crisis in in huge
and compelling problems
um the other thing I've been asked was
um I think it's really really good but
what's available for those who can't
access that such as those on Logistics
type trimmers
a lot of people like that another
question was
um how are people made well the variety
of services that you've got there
because I know of them
um and people often I'm willing to go to
their GP I don't want to walk on
um so I had people get to know about
them all
um if they're not you know if they're
lonely then they're isolated how would
they hear about these and I was
wondering about social prescriptions I'm
just wondering about is it is there a
way of social describing without Synergy
and all of these services
thank you would you like me to start so
I'll bring bring colleagues in so again
some really really good questions so you
loved it right the services that we're
providing are really supporting people
with quite significant mental health
needs and as you'll know nationally
Mental Health Services we want to keep
coming that's the funding because our
services typically haven't been funded
at the same pace of some other services
and that means those services are
focused in really of those people's Fair
than tolerance and there's a whole
spectrum of needs out there
um there are a number of developments so
certainly here in Trafford in recent
years we've been able to support some of
our GP and the Primary Care Network
colleagues with a national scheme to
expand mental health practitioners in
general practice
um in addition to NHS talking therapist
which is better people counseling to
um to psychological therapeutic input
which is self-referable healing trackers
we we've also I think Claire mentioned
the Living Well Service which again is
another National Initiative for people
who at the moment their needs probably
couldn't be met through when talking
therapy service or through a GP but they
don't quite need the criteria of system
of known as civilian mental illnesses so
that's starting to become an expanded
service in in traffic although it's
still working progress to provide people
with more support and then that broader
um
indicators of well-being we do have a
greater Management Mental Health and
well-being strategy which has just been
redeveloped which is really something to
look at employment and housing and
keeping people in school and all the
people you would be very familiar with
and I think our chocolate colleagues are
also we're working with Partners
um you may well hear from from America
as well around developing a traffic
version of that too because you're
absolutely right some of those drivers
of mental health and your ability to
deal with your mental health will come
from the your early experiences to
um
and I should just say our vcse
colleagues are absolutely fundamental in
that um they they pay pivotal role
um in supporting people
um in terms of talking therapists there
are this is a bit of a fourth Bridge job
in terms of raising awareness trying to
access people the service was a huge
amount of work and I suspect we'll need
to keep doing a huge amount of work to
raise awareness for people as I say even
if anybody here takes that nice and
takes at home it's self-referring
Services you can all start system
through your GP the access times are
really good but we do need to do more
advisor prescribed National model
um but we want everybody to be aware of
that
acceptable also provide a postcode
service for people who are struggling
with long covered for people with
physical health needs but for all sorts
of people so there's anybody's needs
that we don't think have been that here
in Trafford then we're very happy to
take our back to the services if we can
do more that service is also offered in
a combination of in-person appointments
across Trafford and also online again to
try and help people access the service
in a way that students the best
um and then in terms of a variety of
services and how people are aware again
it's we can't do enough to amaze the
ones we have all sorts of
um publicity we try and use social media
we try and do all sorts of things
through our particularly working with
our partners as well
um a really important
um support for people as our crisis
helpline as well that's available 24
hours a day seven days a week to anybody
who wants to go to whether they're in
touch with services or not
um so again if we can just raise that
here but if there are more things we can
do some of these services will be
accessed through when we directly
accessible by our traffic residents
being as a professional who will refer
them on the similar directly accessible
we just want to make sure they're
available to the public as much as we
can so anything we can do to improve
that we're really happy to see
um just going back to colleagues is
there anything else that you want to
mention there are a number of people who
actually say maybe don't know how to
access or where and we do we're doing an
awful lot of work with our colleagues in
the Northwest Ambulance Service and
great and I'm just a police for people
who access Services by those routes so
we're doing lots and lots of work
um with those agencies about how we can
appropriately divert people the Right
Care by the right person with those
right expertise so that's a big Journey
because they're big numbers across both
Manchester but it's definitely an area
of a proud
thank you I've got two uh two areas I
want to ask about and the first one is
around
um governance and speaking up
um so there's there's plenty of stories
in the media regularly about failures of
political governance and um people
blowing the whistle not being listened
to
um Boards of NHS trust and I haven't
preparation of those concerns
um and I guess here you've got
um you know first of all thank you to
speak to them thank you for taking on
the challenge of trying to deliver this
Improvement plan for the trust but I
guess here you've got
um new board members who've got new
executive appointments you you're
getting new non-executive directors and
you've recruited new stuff which is
obviously great but a lot of new people
coming into the trust and kind of
supports about the culture and
um
was being appointed and champions have
been
recruited so I think my question is if
given all those new people coming into
the trust I know there's been an
increase in the concerns raised but
um what ways do you have of monitoring
whether people are feeling speak up
whether those concerns are passed on to
managers in the executive whether
they're bored or properly putting the
picture about those concerns so I don't
know if you have a staff survey or when
we discuss other trade unions and that
sort of things that's my first question
and then my second one of the late shows
just around the financial challenges
that you that you mentioned
um and the talking report of under
investment I think of 90 million pounds
that I can't find enough but I've got a
figure of my head for some reason
um and funding challenges I mentioned I
just wanted to be are able to
quantify those I was at a meeting early
week about cam services and and the
non-recurring sources of funding are
essentially
disappearing to a large extent because
of the introduction to the ICB so I just
want to give you if you're able to
quantify the financial challenges that
the Trustmark based that might represent
the rest of the Improvement plan thank
you
and
so I think you've picked up one that we
have investors in previous pickup
Guardians and having a whole system and
of Champions and that's from the world
and to the world and really we have a
champion at uh or not as executive
command executive I think and really
Embrace enough culture to be open and
transparent and that's what we've tried
to do your rights because new people
coming all the time but new people bring
fresh Airlines which I think is really
helpful um to wear whereas as an
organization and we do
um have reporting to through to the
board in terms of uh the themes and the
types of things that are coming up and
through freedom to speak up and we do
discuss goals and and look at how we um
how we respond to those in a
considerably because some of those might
seem very simple but to people and you
know then they may be a you know a big
issue on what we want to get to is get
to the stage where people and can raise
issues naturally and normally through
supervision through and online managers
and all the people they have to go
through a garden and if the guardian is
kind of like the safe space and you
should require it so I think you know
what I've seen is that and new to the
organization was that I have seen quite
a lot of freedom to speak up and very
much and being encouraged by everybody
and accept it as a as um a way forward
in terms of our culture
um and I think we want to embrace that
in terms of with that additional
investment well equally we want to have
staff that feel confident and comforted
to in their roles whatever those roles
are good and feel confident to be able
to have those open discussions and
debates in their teens about concerns
whether they be safety concerns whether
there be staff concerns whether they be
just you know concerns and issues and I
think that's our efficient to get to the
people will feel confident to be able to
have that open discussion wherever that
may be and that your guiding is kind of
the bad stuff but at the moment you're
really um reinforcing that reason to
speak up and principle
so you've got the whole beginning just
as a financial challenge at the moment
and I guess there's
two things first of all is our existing
services today
um we are we are aimed to have a
balanced plan
um we have to and that's really
important
um however we are able to you've heard
there's some things that we're investing
in as well so we're trying to balance
and make measured decisions about making
sure our services are safe and we're
investing with the right posts whilst
also doing our very best to make sure
with the efficient effective so we do
have a challenge this year
um
and it just provides across a great
adventure it may also be aware that
um there's a national focus on greater
Manchester NHS finances as well and at
the moment we're all being nationally
scrutinized but for every level of
emerging control that we can put in
place so we have the same challenge
um in terms of our current service
provision the Gap that you mentioned
um is put that's come from
um an analysis of spend the mental
health services compared with need
across England so when you look at the
average England expenditure in each OCB
I go to Manchester total mental health
funds that's not just for people occurs
at the sort of specialist sentimental
across all bcsc and the Departments
we're in the lowest quartile for the
country so if greater Manchester spends
the average for England based on need
that would be another 90 million into
the greater Manchester mental health
system not not just for us but across
the level at the range of needs that's
where that's come from we're very
pleased that the um the greatest
registered ICB is committed to sort of
universal access and leveling up funding
over its five-year job forward plan as
well and obviously we'll work with the
last one of the Mental Health Partners
on the priorities for that investment
that's a future plan as opposed to
today's pressures which we absolutely
have but we're very focused on making
sure that we are recruiting people into
post because our services need to be
safe and improvising therapeutic support
thank you
thank you very much and to speak with us
this evening officer the challenge is
absolutely immense but
your commitment to
um
my colleagues have asked a lot around
culture and that's really
weird
about culture about the service use
advice and the both of the carer and are
you able to expand on that a little bit
more about the measures that you are
taking to really ensure that certain
juices and Care responses are ahead and
they're able to shape someone to start
from going forward as well
and yes and so we have a strategy which
is around Services of care engagement
and most NHS organizations really start
to have that
and but we've also added us into our
Improvement plan about strengthening and
the voice of people with lived
experience
um and in doing that we're looking for
structures to enable that to happen so
we will be developing
um
Services here at Council and that
Council was set
um if you think of the architecture of
our our board will sit next to the board
and advise the board and those people
would be people with lived experience
Sports services and carers and that's
what about making sure that in terms of
service delivery service improvement and
transformation we are listening to
people that have that lived experience
then each of our care groups will have a
certitude of care and local Council and
that will work similarly and then within
each of our services as part of our
safer Staffing reviews we will be making
sure that we appear and support workers
so people with lived experience being
part of our teams that deliver care that
starts to kind of get some kind of
architecture and we are having
conversations about uh and working with
and some of the voluntary sector around
what does co-production mean what does
it look like how do we make this
strategy come to life and so that it's
not populistic but it's actually
meaningful and as our board meeting this
month we're going to have a conversation
about a presentation of somebody with
lived experience who know um is a peer
support worker and has got a vision
about how we as a church should take
that forward so we'll be listening to
him and
um and having that discussion so it's
about making sure that lived experience
is a golden thread and obviously there's
going to be um challenges in that in
terms of enabling our services and chaos
to be able to to speak and contribute
contribute to the meaningful way but
also helping our staff shift to a
culture where people with different
experience are prior to the multi
routine now it would be the Mysteries I
did mention that obviously we have staff
have a good experience and we always
have done and therefore her life will do
so it's really embracing that lived
experience about how that can add added
value into really getting to what we
should be delivering just into
individualized processes there and
really blind side of all that we will be
developing a process Center Care
framework which is really kind of
getting some nuts and thoughts about
what this person sentiments look like
um and what it doesn't look like and
also we're going to be looking at
probably moving to
um and this is very early days so it's
nothing to a board yet but I'll be
proposing that we'll move to to using a
tool called dialogue plus which is a
tool that you work very collaboratively
between the person with lived experience
their family and the professional and
the very much focus on outcomes that the
patient wants to have as part of their
treatment in this part of their plan and
that's something that sort of contrasts
nationally I've started to move and use
and has seen really really positive
feedback from service users and what
that doesn't really shift the way we
deliver services and mental health and
to be very much collaborative and and
person-centered
so that's that's the plan in terms of
how we're going to bring all of that to
yours
thank you thank you that's for the
progressive class some permanent
questions so
um
so another thing that you talked about
was a big priority is about smoking
cessation because the instance of
smoking the most people are planning
health concerns is significantly higher
isn't it in the general population and
also about
um intervention being more therapeutical
taking place in a therapeutic
environment and we'll see that those two
things
just tell us a little bit more
and
as I mentioned earlier is challenging
because a lot of our patients and smoke
and we do know that the literature was
out they're like 20 years younger so we
have to make sure that we're really at
our staff already permisses and
understand that but also have a service
users to understand their life
expectancy impact this morning so a lot
of the work that I mentioned earlier as
well because our inpatient Awards we
equally have had a problem of supporting
people in the community around smoking
cessation and you know and that has has
different
um uh different strands to it so people
are you replacing cigarettes for example
with
um nicotine management products
um babes you know there's a whole
there's a whole piece on that and but
it's about the education and development
that we give our staff to enable that
support to service users
um in terms of the therapeutic
environment
um you know there's a whole piece of
work that we've we've started as the
most embedding in what does therapeutic
environment look like and looks like in
modern mental health and it isn't
um it isn't but I guess some people
experience so it's very much shifting
into the staff establishments obviously
will make a difference to that but
things that we will have is uh
therapeutic activities that are seven
days a week so currently they're five
days a week and seven days a week making
sure that all our staff are trained and
been able to do an individual therapy
with patients or group therapy as well
to kind of bringing back some some
things also having to focus on physical
health and because the medication does
have an impact on people's and health
and well-being physical health and
well-being so making sure that we have
gyms and exercise equipment but that we
have staff that are trained together
important to do that so all of those
things together
will change that environment with that
and that will change the culture but for
me we have to get the stuff through the
door and educate the develop them should
be culture culture but unless we do that
it's it's particularly a kind of
scenario so
um so you know there's a lot of work
that we're doing
um but but it's also very positive
because for the future and you know
we've got an opportunity really changing
what inpatient care looks like
um for people that really really need it
but that kind of goes handful of the
whole Community transformation the
national problem that they're mentioned
which is about one of the single most uh
significant change in mental health
services in 30 years and so it's it's
really important that we we work on the
inpatient therapeutic but also make sure
that we're doing that prevention and
we're doing that support of people in
the community as well
thank you very much
[Music]
um
on a ballpark how many vacancies medical
medicine sorry do you have across Trust
apologies we will have that in a report
but not one we've got with us
unfortunately it's definitely higher
than we want it to be
um and we've got all the breakdowns of
all the Staffing groups as well I think
it goes in our public World performance
report too I just don't have it in front
of me I am so very happy sending the
information after the meeting but it is
higher than we want it to be absolutely
is the final question for me actually uh
in terms of the voluntary services that
you know I'd like to mentioned what kind
of capacity do they have
is there something in there
on the age of being able to support
thank you
yeah we work very closely with blue sky
and meet with them regularly so the
Living Well the Living Well Service is
just a part of what Blue Sky do in terms
of um
um social prescribing or working with
our service working with our service
users so there's a whole range of
services and they Link in with probably
and who is all the bcse
providers as well so it's just part of a
whole picture and I think it's I think
it's fair to say that they see an
increase in demand as well and
um
and I think we can see that sort of
across the across the system as well but
for for corrosive in Trafford we would
really try we're really wanting we have
started this with the living world and
we really want to take it Forward into
the community transformation as well
about working very differently with the
third sector as well because they can
just offer so much and bring
um such a different view different
experience
um difference a different skill level in
in a lot of cases to services and makes
it a much richer and environment for our
service users and our residents
cool thank you uh thank you very much
for that very candidate of course
um
and so look forward to the positive
external review that's taking the place
[Music]
um
okay thank you
it's a
I could find a traffic locality Network
Health care
where would you mind
got some friends with us
thank you
[Music]
of the greater Manchester strategy the
the way that that's translating into a
local repressionized strategy and also
some Crossover with an absolute
discussions
so I think probably some of it and I'm
trying not to repeat
um so firstly I I hope that the overview
of the the GM strategy is helpful it's a
broad context
to the work of the trumpet systems
developing in terms of mental health and
well-being the that GM strategy of
course is reflective of the 2022
reorganization which brought 10 ccgs
um into one Central gym organization
um when I read that strategy I I take
some great positives and I think they're
reflected in some of the things that
colleagues have said for only greater
Manchester mental health
um because they're emphasizing the
benefits of an integrated public service
system
inclusive of our bcfse colleagues I'm
really glad to hear the the positive way
in which health colleagues are talking
about our partners in the voluntary
sector but also the place that citizens
play Within design and delivery and I
think over time particularly perhaps in
only disability and autism Services I
think we've seen how transparency
openness listening to the people we work
for actually enhances safety reduces
risk and wins upon you with just one of
those examples over time I think it's
also great that the GM strategy is
emphasizing The Wider determinants of
mental health it's very limited actually
what we can achieve with a purely held
model determinants of Health sit outside
of appeals and diagnosis they sit in
housing this is in money they sit in the
food we eat so those social determinants
are incredibly important
so I suppose I would suggest that it's
probably the broader system challenges
and whether they can be met that will
Define the success of mental health and
well-being transformation across GM and
of course in traffic because we are now
part of GM
so I'd be suggesting I think some of the
challenges these aren't all in these are
just some from my head it is
is how the opportunities we've got
through that system to deliver and scale
translates into really high quality
local Services as a fair
and how it avoids being seen as a way of
cost cutting we've heard the financial
pressures they are huge and I really
would say they don't just sit within
Health they sit across the system so
they're huge so deliberate scale fairly
and not as a way of cutting costs
necessarily
how will we make sure that co-production
and lived experience plays into those
big design areas and again great to hear
the commitment to it coming from
colleagues and I think we've got a
really strong story to Southern trumpet
around that we commissioned what we call
the a Citizens Forum that that's counted
over to when it's always to date that's
helped us design The Living Well I
personally go out at least once a month
and meet the people who are experiencing
mental health and well-being challenges
and it transforms
um
how within that centralization of Health
Services do we get a really clear
understanding of locality in the
neighborhood in terms of Designing and
developing services
and I think there is a really
significant question to be asked
regarding the capacity that's remaining
within the system across the various
health and care agencies to deliver
efficiencies through further integration
um the financial challenge we've spoken
about it's really significant
um
demand is rising not always in numbers I
have to say but certainly impurity I
think that's really reflecting the
hospital it's served by colleagues
across the room and also Workforce it's
often just simply not rare so there are
huge challenges out there so that's just
an overview of that of the GM strategy
in terms of how that translates through
into the locality mental health and
well-being strategy
um I'm not going through the detail that
you've got the paper I know you've read
it and I know you'll ask questions if
you need to
but that paper too gives you an overview
both of the achievements that is driven
as a result of the existing strategy
which has been there since 2020 to 2021
now
it also have the new refreshed all those
strategy which will reflect the greater
Manchester vision and again we're
hearing and our major providers are also
adopting those five challenges they're
adopting that strategy so the system is
coalescing around a single division
that's hugely helpful when it comes to
how do we deliver how to reach your
quality how do we ensure safety
um I hope it's helpful to laying out
some of those initial descriptors of how
Health Service design and delivery is
envisaged in terms of what
responsibility sit at GM and what's it
in locality that probably is one of our
most significant challenges how do we
understand the needs of locality and
don't waste the opportunities we've got
to deliver a scale and thereby building
efficiencies that can translate into
better local services
so the refresh strategy that actually I
distribute the first draft last night
yes it will have a different form
but I think it's really important to
emphasize that we're going to continue
to emphasize the importance of the
underpinning work so it's underpinned
with data it's undependent analysis
we're going to continue ensuring as far
as we can hearing what colleagues have
said that our existing services are
resilient
where we see things can be improved and
we will always look towards reform and
redesign in partnership with Citizens
We're really committed to co-design
living well is an absolute example of
that we could not have come up with the
model to come up with unless we listen
to stores
um and of course we are absolutely
committed to reducing Health
inequalities and ensuring the prevention
under the intervention that are part of
everything we do
um we've of course heard from gmh
colleagues about some of the challenges
that exist within the system but I would
say we've got some really good news to
tell in Trafford and it is interesting
sitting in Europe you were asking
questions and probably at some of which
I believe that's brilliantly but were
probably better directed at me
um great to hear about the the
enthusiasm for the voluntary sector
we've got great Public Health Services
which Claire will talk to us about but
in particular I think the living well
service is a fantastically good and used
story but we should be celebrating and
I'll talk a little bit more about that
just in a moment but first can I just
wonder if it's declare we'd included a
whole Suite of work that's being led by
our Public Health colleagues in the
strategies exempt as examples both were
already doing but what will continue to
do and we're going to build alongside
that examples from Health and Care just
okay good evening and police I'm Claire
with some of my public health consults
and I've recently joined the public
health Team here in Trafford local
Authority I just wanted to take a few
minutes for you to highlight uh our role
uh Public Health in shining the light on
the opportunities for prevention and
ensuring the proportionate effort
actually is invested in supporting
trafford's population to remain mentally
well and to avoid that kind of
escalation that lead to the point where
we're seeing uh advising demand so yes
it's about steering demand but equally I
think it's about recognizing mental
health as an asset right across the life
course you know it's a crucial part of
early years development it impacts on
school attainment
it determines our transition into
education employment and training so for
all those reasons for wider family
functioning and some of the things I've
heard already it's important that we get
the prevention offer integrated within
that wider
transformation of mental health so I
just wanted to take an opportunity to
highlight and it will just be
highlighted I know there's a larger
gender Still Still scope
um but we have we did a very quick
mapping of uh Public Health work against
the five GM strategic missions and I'll
just highlight a number of those so in
terms of people being part mentally
healthy safe and supportive families
workplaces and communities I wanted to
highlight the work that Trafford health
and well-being board are doing in terms
of setting a smart goal for all
employers that sit on the board to
commit to becoming living wage
accredited and that a third commit to
work towards good employment Charter by
April 2024 we know the meaningful work
being valued having Financial
rewards and income is vital to our
mental health so that's a really pretty
short uh commitment that we're delighted
that the board is is focusing on and
work is on the way in terms of the
neighborhood plans to include strategic
priorities on Mental Health just to
highlight social isolation and
loneliness amongst older people it's
been highlighted as a priority within
the staff neighborhood that's just an
example of the work that will be
featuring part those neighborhood plans
as they develop further
um the second mission around quality of
life being improved by inclusive timely
access to high quality mental health
information support and services a large
arm of public Health's work is to ensure
that we promote the support that's
available that it reaches the
populations who are most at risk and
that we also promote the offers that GM
have available around training for
Workforce and it's ensuring that we get
those targeted to the population
most just quickly touching in terms of
people with long-term mental health
conditions we chat for Council has
commissioned Blue Sky Community Mental
Health and wellbeing service to deliver
a new Specialist of smoking services for
those arming SMI register we've already
heard about that work but I guess it's
well equally important to highlight
examples such as investment of Mental
Health Services in stakeholder groups
the Leisure Center investment program
and ensuring well we've got Advanced
discussions underway about the
co-location of Mental Health Services in
less Services that's really important
because we know the protective fact that
physical activity plays in relation to
our mental health
um
or just quickly say a final word then on
in terms of mission five which is about
mental health and well-being so it's
recognizing the inequality
discrimination and structural inequity
that people experience and there is a
high prevalence in the co-occurring
conversational needs in mental health
and alcohol and drug treatment services
and in community settings and we have
identified a priority to improve the
referral Pathways between Healthcare
settings and drug and alcohol treatment
services and and also just finally say
that we must ensure that Insight through
the property truth commission and the
mental health inequalities work is
undertaken a year ago now feeding and a
reflective is the Trafford all age
mental power strategies so we will be
working in public health very closely
with richness due to ensure that
simply
thanks glad that was fantastic
um so just to finish a brief update
around really well just picking up on
some of the players just said
um we're slightly more than working
towards co-locating and we actually are
co-located we've got Jim and H staff
actually co-located with blue sky in our
traffic room house and also a copies
Library I believe
we're getting there
um with with strong work in progress to
co-workout across all before areas of
Trafford it's a fantastic development
um
um so just a really brief a few words
about the leading Well Service
um the two previous papers that Gian the
people strategy both describe co-design
they describe the importance of
incorporating lived experience into the
designer services and how important it
is that they do things differently if
we're going to achieve a step change in
mental health and well-being
the greater Manchester and the traffic
strategies emphasize how important it is
to understand the impact of trauma if
we're going to help people recover and
there was a question around trauma
earlier which was which was great to
hear and those 200 stories that our
citizens told us I think I'm writing
saying
every single one spoke at trauma
um its impact and that shift towards
talking to people about what happened to
them as opposed to what's wrong with
them I think is perhaps one of the most
transformative ships
so traffic Living Well in bodies all of
those strands which I think is why such
a great story and and it's transforming
the offer to people experiencing mental
health and well-being challenges in
traffic
the paper I've given to you is the copy
of a presentation but I don't apologize
for that because I think it does give
you it gives you the story of Living
Well it gives you the progress it gives
you how close we are to Rolling that
service out across all five Primary Care
networks and four four areas of our
locality
some of the key elements quickly that I
just would like to emphasize back in
2018 there are about a thousand people
all in between the services in traffic
they weren't receiving the canvas what
they needed they didn't they wouldn't
they weren't able to be careful by GPS
they were often too complex they weren't
really meeting the criteria Professional
Services they were falling into avoid
they're not falling into avoid anymore
so that's a fantastic piece of good news
the power of Citizen stories I just
don't think we can overemphasize it
um trauma we've spoken about but equally
people spoke incredibly badly about how
complicated our systems are and how we
need to simplify them one front door one
entry point and at that point we talk to
people and work out what they need and
we get them there quickly
Primary Care is where people spend their
lives it's the one part of the Health
Service where we stand up pretty much
the whole of Our Lives particularly if
we don't move out of an area and so
aligning Mental Health Services with
primary care networks is profoundly
living well does that
integrating services in this case health
and dcfsc the blue sky is is so
significant I think it actually has
incredible cultural benefits for all the
organizations involved but just the same
we've got a great range of SE the
question was asked about capacity
we have age UK we're at the carer center
42nd Street
crisis some fantastic reliers yes
they're challenged by the rising demand
but they're fantastic services and
without them I don't know what we do on
top of that of course
so we've got a great range of provisions
getting closer to citizens in
neighborhoods and listening to stories
absolutely does not mean abandoning
we're both clinical practice and outcome
measures and living well is very very
strong in measuring outcomes and making
sure that the services that are being
delivered because they are new and they
are revolutionary and we are learning
from them are actually achieving
outcomes of people
and then lastly I just wanted to
re-emphasize good physical health good
physical health care is indivisible from
good mental health care we talk about
parity of esteem it means something it
means that at the moment mental health
is not treated with the same importance
and often the same respect as physical
health care services the funding can
reflect that we have to keep fighting
support Mental Health on an equal
playing field
and then just a very very final comment
is to emphasize the next steps living
well we're nearly there but the next
steps I think are equally if not more
exciting than those those steps of the
redesigning our specialist Services
Community Mental Health teams our
inpatient services
how do we get those closer to our
citizens and our neighborhoods our
localities if we can do that in the same
figure and the same person senses as we
did Living Well I think we will make a
huge step change in the provision of
services not just in traffic but across
the country
thank you
thank you are there any questions
[Music]
it's really Innovative isn't it
really needs to be in the in the uh
the information about Television
services in pleasure you know and it's
part of 16 between that sort of physical
health you know it's about these Spears
so thank you very much for sharing all
this with us
because
I just ask don't ask more for more
detail about what they're planning
school so you
and we are working in schools there's a
large program of workers away including
suspects such as healthy schools mental
health support teams
um hot girls around so there is thrive
in education group at specifically looks
at that and it includes work for early
years settings right back
it just starts that very briefly I think
I think the question is is well poned
it's also why we're putting such a huge
emphasis on making sure that the
strategy moves away
um being slightly but you know
prevention is actually the same as
investing in our kids because we don't
do that we're just storing our trouble
for the future so absolutely that's why
the strategies
yeah
well thank you for that uh
oh sorry well um
is that what you should be one in nine
children itself
have mental health issues and I
understand the importance of when when
it's going to happen but is that mental
health offer
now because I know um students are
experiencing
children not coming into School
attendance levels down and it's really
interesting how some schools have
adapted to that and I just wanted
for that to happen into in rather than
looking into the future with without
wishing to dock the question at all
um my my responsibilities are up across
the adult mental health agenda but what
we can do absolutely if I ask um South
Africans to prepare some information
that would reassure you around that I
personally don't have those no I'm just
interested because to get a healthy
and
developmentally and physically it's at
the start of course
Massachusetts
[Music]
foreign
amen
sure
thank you yeah but then just to add the
neighborhood model is working very very
closely
and with the family hopes as well so
you've got that environment with the
offer of children people
um
[Music]
neighborhood in particular so we've got
that lead across between the health
insurance
if
okay thank you I've just been around the
at the children of scrutiny committee
about a task and finish piece of work on
the children's mental health and voting
lessons so so we can share that report
I'm sure that piece of work is ongoing
through there and so it's really
I've been through tonight with some
detail in that kind of thing thank you
well I've been a little great enthusiasm
and we can just hope that in order to
translate into something simpler
efficient and more effective uh
[Music]
thank you
thank you introduction from me and then
just okay
thank you
there's a few quick introductory
comments for me then hopefully people
have a chance to have a look at the
slide that came out of this is part of
an engagement that we've been doing with
a scrutiny committee for probably about
a year and a half and since we first
went into this piece of work ever even
before we started piece of work so
hopefully most people got aware of that
we thought to review a version cash
services in Trafford September 2022 I
think he won from just to recap on slide
two just why we did that and the main
reason
why they need to ensure that we have an
urgent and emergency care system that is
simple to navigate it meets the needs of
all of the Trafford residents and
traffic
population also I think we need to
ensure that that needs based on health
inequality and so so we have the need is
addressing the right part of the borough
but also to have an eye on the financial
and Staffing Resources that are
available
and also the National Guard so the first
phase of this piece of work was very
much around engaging with residents and
partners to understand what the need of
the population was out I just want to
put on record if you thank you to the
number of people it was a huge number of
people from Trafford it took part in the
survey and they need the working groups
we had to perform what we've got now
which is a really rich
information to support us moving forward
and so we've committed to give regular
updates to exclusion committee so this
is one of the stage so what I'll do is
hand over
to Kathy and Jay and to talk through
some of the initial findings and then
concentrate on the next steps of the
process we've moved through
thanks Kathy James
I appreciate it this stresses
thank you and I'm confident
director of delivering transformation
for transport housing and so as as
promised and that's agreed we've come
back with basically where we are in this
phase of the review I'm sure you can see
from the slide deck on slide three and
there's four very specific phases so we
are now in the engagement on and
classical models we are developing
proposals and models which we hope and
James will go through some of the detail
of what those models might look like
reflects the outputs in the outside of
the view so what we wanted to do is
basically say this is what the review
has been telling us based on how common
qualities Health needs Urgent Care
access and just for clarification for
those who might not affect all detailed
documents when we're talking about the
Urgent Care review we're talking about
not access to
Urgent Treatment Centers or a e we're
encompassing everything from a pharmacy
from Dentistry from Optometry so it's
wine ranging accessible services and
also it is all age so it's not just
specifically to adults how it's it's all
age
services so we're in the engagement
phase as we've made as I've just uh just
said what we wanted to do is just bring
back
um the outputs a very brief summary of
the output to review there was a setlist
and that was it's already been
circulated and it was circulated price
to meet and just referred information
but we just wanted to summarize
personally what we did in relation to
the needs assessment so I'm sure you've
read in the documentation we did
extensive patient and public engagement
James we're both listen to the key
findings on that
um Desktop review of all previous
engagement activity we had we um
obviously had very much with our um of
what colleagues and Heather has sat on
all the development groups in relation
to the review but also we had an
independent report report and Analysis
done by healthwatch
to give us an independent view of what
urgent care and access to urgent care
services look like we had six public
drop-in sessions we did an online survey
and we made specific focus on addressing
demographic gaps so we did reviews of
responses of our engagement activity to
make sure we were trying to reach all of
those potentially harder to reach groups
Trafford and to make it as as wide
ranging as we possibly could and we had
extensive data analysis in relation to
transport Health Services but extremely
socially important in public health
colleagues in relation to health
inequalities and demographics so we
really feel that we've got a very
extensive Global Urgent Care review so
what we're doing now is coming back with
the stages to build out now which is
basically what the review has told us
but also what steps and James will talk
through the seven priority areas that
we've identified to reflect what we
believe collectively by we I mean in
stakeholders and so that includes our
healthwork colleagues our mft colleagues
our wider bcse police Community Services
what we've done is collectively
discussed with them and learned about
what the review told us and then
identified seven priority areas that we
believe reflect the key elements within
that review to make it very succinct and
then our proposals that we looked up
there and put together a number of
options of how we best believe we can
mitigate what that review has told us so
from the seven priority areas basically
this is what the review is telling us
and then the proposals of how we might
initiate some of those potential gaps
Manchester
[Music]
in Trafford and so yeah as Kathy has
alluded to for the slide that well maybe
suggest is if we skip Slide Five because
you've probably already seen that when
we last attended and we talked about the
Urgent Care needs assessment so you'll
probably be familiar with most of the
information on Slide Five already
between slide steps is the important
thing so this is the one that Kathy
alluded to in terms of the help watch
review in terms of the survey that we'd
already done with patients we had over
600 responses which I think you know
those of you've been involved in service
place
and so we had over sexual responses and
healthwatch provided the analysis that
obviously the independent analysis
around that and the outputs of that
survey and what we found was that people
were generally aware of services that
were available in the system moved from
a primary care perspective and also from
secondary cantones of what those core
main Services
have been available
one of the issues that we did identify
with patients we were a little bit
concerned around not being able to get
GP appointments but I think what you'll
see as we go through the information is
a lot of this is probably sort of backed
up by I think at the moment very much
um media Insight in terms of there's a
big feeling within the system about how
patients are accessing services and we
know we know ourselves you know we
Facebook groups and those sort of things
that's the sort of messages
sort of development what we wanted to do
though as we work through this in more
detail
Kathy's mentioned this already in terms
of seven priority areas let's get a
little bit more standing around that so
whilst there will be some um key
findings that we're looking at what
we're now in this stage of is actually
exploring that in more detail to
actually dig down into it and understand
it from an addressing each level really
at the moment so that's where we are and
there was obviously some praise for
individual practices and we pulled that
up from a lot of the uh includes that
we've had and there was concern around
waiting times at emergency departments
and in terms of the following our
standard and I think given the position
and the improvements that we've made
over recent months across the main sites
I think maybe about now and asking the
same question that may reduce slightly
and if you have seen some significant
improvements in our performance mental
health was obviously identified in an
area of concern we have not touched on
Mental Health within this area for a
number of reasons obviously just heard
from Rick college and gmh we don't want
to duplicate out of here so we are
leaving
Mental Health
whilst we've identified it as areas of
focus and concern we recognize the
amount of work that's taking place
already within the system
it's not with a duplicate so that's one
of the reasons we kind of focus on
Mental Health specifically and there was
Olympics turn around then patients being
unsure about where to go for certain
Services how to access certain services
so I think there's what you'll see
within a lot of the information probably
from the data that we've already
collected there's this training of
um so that golden thread again around
Communications and engagement so Tom
Cruise um who's on the other side of the
table he's been he's been sharing one of
that and fantastic finished groups
focusing specifically around content
engagement and how we can improve that
involvement in terms of what sort of
music system and so ultimately around
one of the priority areas that we focus
on moving forward and again people
Express and concern around physical
information has been available around
where to go there's a lot of digital
digital is obviously with big book
around digital actually going back to
that have a lot of leaflet I've got a
fire and I think actually all the
members have a
reason to put through there that's
boxing recently about getting to know
where to go so that's just a prime
example of what we could do in the
system
what was science what is available to
patients anymore and then last but not
least consider the voice around
pharmacies and access to pharmacies this
is a natural issue with some pharmacies
at the moment so we have a look into
that separately from this piece of work
and when I was working with a helicopter
around us in
2016 actually Trafford is a resource
from the pharmacy's perspective we have
more resources than from the pharmacy
point of view than the national average
so we are quite well we are conscious
there are some chains and maybe pulling
out some supermarkets and but even if
that does happen from a traffic
perspective we are still above the
national average
and so yeah just moving on from a survey
analysis point of view what we also
um identify when we came to look at the
service resources with particular trains
are for within the responses we're
getting about from the public around
areas of concern and they've
predominantly identify there within the
North and the West around practices
specifically so what we've done as part
of one of the task computers groups
specifically we're now engaging the
practices in the those areas to
understand what's actually happening
from that perspective because we've got
the patient perception and we've got the
um information we've got within the
survey but actually what we need to
understand now is what's happening with
around my pal patients accessing GPS is
there any issues is there anything in
terms of and you know can patients
access at particular times that they the
whole reason different elements that we
need to consider
perspective so they're the sort of
conversations we're having at a moment
within those task confusion
and
so yeah so just moving forward I think
for us as happy as alluded to there are
seven priority areas which you should be
able to see on slide nine and and that
is focusing around improving triage and
assessments around Trafford General
Hospital from both developing a
consistent advantage of primary care so
that's predominantly focusing around the
pharmacy and actually if you turn up a
pharmacy and you've got Healthcare and
leave what happens because there are
certain things in place actually that
helps some of that could be streamlined
so we're looking at pharmacies
specifically improving the communication
engagement of urgent care and that's the
one that's leading on and again that
will be piggybacking on the get to know
where to go campaign there's already a
GM level Campaign at the moment and then
looking are improving our out of hours
offer across profit we know some
feedback we've had from various areas as
well as within the survey at the moment
that actually we can improve our outer
levels and in terms of how patients are
accessing it and it's all looking at
that specifically reducing Primary Care
access variation so for those of you who
may not be aware practices are obviously
independent and sometimes what they
offer really different from one practice
to the next in terms of appointments
that are available or however opens are
accessed digital office face-to-face
telephone works like that so we'll work
you through that with a number of
practices at the moment to make sure
that that's improved and then another
one is around streaming patients between
primary care
and how that can be made looks like
focusing predominantly around one-on-one
so at the moment practices need to make
a certain amount of questions available
to
um to one-on-one into we know that
there's a massive variation of cross
practices so we're going to work with
the practices to improve as well and as
well as some other areas within and
within booking
fluidly across the system and then last
but not least we're going to consider
how we could use uh or should use the
automobile service
look that's the seven priority areas
what you'll find on the next following
slide is around the rationale for that
so what this is is information that's
been taken from the review that we've
done so far also the applicants from the
engagement that we've undertaken and
also the survey as well so that's why
we're focusing on the specific areas
what we do as part of a um a wider
working group we sat down with system
partners and you've got the calf MFC
colleagues in the council GP sat down
and went through all the information
that we've collected so far as part of
the review and within the outputs of the
engagement surveys and said okay which
areas do we need to focus on
specifically and these seven areas of
the output for those conversations and
at the end of this review what we will
have is a really good recommendations
that will move forward to the system to
say this is what you can focus on
the review will not be doing the
implementation we need to be clear about
this you will provide a really good
recommendations based on the information
as far as exercise and then the next
phase which we will come in once a year
will be a program of work after this
review
engagement lots of groups that have been
involved the next stage really is to go
back and workload groups who've been
involved in initial stages around the
engagement Cafe Olympics and actually
update them around what we've done so
far with the new year the priorities
identified and actually sit down with
those you know the patients and the
public and say position it sends to you
or should we do something different you
know so it's actually giving them the
opportunity to feed back on what we
think of so far we need to change it and
again so make sure that we're on the
right track and not going up in the
dungeon
what do you think is the the process of
that review
in in terms of the priorities
[Music]
so those seven priorities so we've
identified and for some priorities
you've got um
we anticipate that the review we hope
will be finished by the end of October
if
[Music]
so the timelines involved in this won't
change for any of those and so we just
wanted to make sure that it they've all
been identified as key areas of
development in the reviews I wanted to
make sure that we have proposals for
each other in the same time period
any questions
picking up on me and that last answer
that you gave that's asking page groups
um
I I mean thanks for the update and and
uh thank you for the the book you guys
the consultation that's happened which
is obviously really extensive my
question is whether
that involvement really at the public
and residents and patient perspective
carries through themselves to pass
through Finnish groups so it strikes me
that
these groups were quite significant in
terms of recommendations as to what
um what ocean treatment and Urgent Care
will look like across breasts so and
mentioned some of the people involved
games but are our residents involved uh
is helpful to involved and local
councilors involved either at a locality
level or a GM levels
thank you
I believe in everyone and some alone a
problem there is across Health and Care
to remove myself
Authority and nhsdm Trafford
um
so I chair the working group on common
engagement and father phase for the
phase one as we describe it and also for
the first priority on the slides which
details the potential amplification and
it gets in our lives well campaign to
address some of the issues between those
outcomes and engagement so that's just
for context so that is that question
you've just asked our counselor is is
the one question that we keep asking
ourselves within the Steering group that
we have so we're at this stage now where
the outline of those seven priorities
are being worked up with all our
stakeholders we are some of those are
very technical and even I don't
Professor understanding the
technicalities that's in a high area of
work and it will be very professionally
focused other areas such as the one I'm
reading on in terms of how would we
benefit from an amplified campaign and
I'm getting to know where to go what
accesses to access Etc definitely deals
with people in motel to show that's a
lot of the opportunities to work
opportunity sector what this classes
we've got in communities to share
information be that physical or digital
and be that stuff in GP surgeries and
community centers inclusive faith and
worship so
that is a definite to my specific piece
of work and I think the programs here in
Google called depend on is there a clear
rationale for involving people's
Catholic in some of those particular in
each of those seven if there is
fantastic a world we need to consult on
what that looks like so what I'm
engaging is required because to do that
is that going visiting and piggybacking
on an existing Health watch relative
just as an example as you're going to
speak into the community collecting the
different membership and there's
obviously there's a million ways we
could do that and we'd be open to
suggestions on what the best way of
doing that is
um or is it having Standalone sessions
with probably something worth mentioning
now all of the information that you've
had prior to this meeting and in this
meeting tonight all of that is being
played back to everyone who's a part in
the first day so everyone into a party
survey everyone into the platform of the
engagement sessions and listening
sessions the drop-in sessions and all of
that information is going to be
available on the GM website hopefully we
commencing Theater which is next week
so that will be available for everyone
we're looking at schedule and again this
is classic depending problem we should
find with this for listening sessions
open to the public in different parts of
the borough to actually test those seven
priorities with people to say does this
feel right are we missing anything is
there any priority and give us your
thoughts and opinions on that so we're
going to do those listening exercises
within the next month or so and again on
the opportunities to build on meetings
that you may have in your uh
would be really welcome so
long story short absolutely allows it
came in to engage and people traveled
within that sort of shaping of those
things
I mean I've certainly encourage you to
keep asking that question because
um we've heard from previous speakers
like living well and how that was
co-designed with patients and got a
successful service it is and
um otherwise it feels like change in
significance has been it's been done to
two people so
there's a I don't care priorities
Workshop that's going to ask about
um
available to public can everybody attend
and
but I guess I guess my concern really
that I want to express is that um you
know those testing finish groups are up
and running that
Farmers coming to the end of that work
and
for me it's not just about
testing out what's being proposed and
listening sessions it's about co-design
what future services will look like so I
would certainly want to encourage parts
to to consider that and so it does serve
our co-designation
[Music]
um
my
lock my residents are rightly concerned
that it is actually already picked up
about Optimum uh mine Rangers
I know it's been closed I know part of
the reasoning why
um I know it's one of those seven blocks
that's there
um are they taking into account when
they come to the solution
the expansion though once one of them
are they taking into account the
distance from the center of options
or the bottom end of hail bonds
how
people are going to get around
um to these auras
and are they taken into account that
we're already seeing
events
not necessarily as a
a major consequence of the Urgent Care
picture but my interest being shot but
as one of the minor consequences
I know
urgent treatment
centered as part of their expansion
but they are inundated
and
and I know there's questions around the
whole Hospital science as well
from a lifting and
we've got to wait at the end of October
or are we going to get more information
sooner about the site itself
and in particular about this minor
injuries in the future
thank you very much and I do understand
it obviously it's made reference to you
in the report and I'm sure you've
probably read or might have read in the
extensive 71 post document we did the
full analysis in relation to access
points transport links and access to
both public transport but I'll also
access to a car so all of that is being
considered as part of
um the proposals and the options for
optional minor interest unit and we'll
be looking at all that information and
obviously the current position is the
position stays remains as is
um in relation to amiu but in relation
to the wider sites in regards to MRI the
William Shore site obviously the very
very specific Focus there was under the
development delivery of the Urgent
Treatment Centers so please be assured
that all of the potential options for
alternate minority unit will be
considered and when we talk about things
about options we're talking about and
obviously is it remain as a standalone
man which is unique should it be
developed or integrated further into
learning and treatment centers or as per
National guidance or are we looking at
developing it more into a primary care
and hope all of those elements are being
considered or considered using the
extensive data and flows of information
that we already have and we're really
very aware and acutely aware based on
the information that's in the review is
that for the ultraum area specifically
their access to both transport links and
also to access to a car I'm sure there
might be other information and that
others might want to come in with but
it's quite extensive within that area
it's not an area that we would see
potentially as a deprived area that has
weaker or lesser links in regards to
transport Etc but the purposes of doing
the review is to look at that extensive
Suite information and make some proposed
recommendations about what the potential
best options are for that site and the
future of amiu
yeah
we do need to be clear when we talk
about Ultra we're not talking about the
hospital we were talking about a small
service in the hospital so we're not
talking about the whole site itself all
the outpatient services
Radiology actually that remains in the
site and remains being used to this
thing so we're talking if anyone's been
to the main interviews so I'm not four
doors
granted what we've seen is that shift of
patients who used to go to oxygen now go
to women shop we've seen online for like
me I can show you on the graphics in
fact it's in the report you can see it
quite clearly there's a shift of
patients and mulching amounts of wooden
short site
anything
so that is very very important when
we've had these descriptions that
actually have been seen in the
appropriate service now
thank you
and it's just about the pharmacies
um and the important part that they play
into the primary care as well and
um there's something about prescriptions
not being made
is it the pharmacy or to the doctors
um because
very good question
[Music]
um we'll depend on individual
circumstances about what the
relationships have been sorry the
electronic relationship is between the
pharmacy and the GP practice and the
majority work very seriously where it's
automatically trying to learn the
prescription but it depends on policies
on an individual basis as well so if
you've got any very specific uses
obviously please let us know and we'll
look into those individually for you but
um we've not had any significant
complaints whatsoever about Pharmacy
provision on the provision of scripts
and just please
Pharmacy services and some potential
queries and concerns I think the issue
very specifically on the information
that we have is it about Partington
specifically and about the access during
the weekend periods obviously we've
addressed that and are addressing that
on a regular basis to make sure there's
adequate provision in the
um the Washington area and I think it's
there's so much in love there's so much
data in there it's really hard what
we've had to do is make it in um to
budget them into very specific areas
where we have quite a lot of feedback
and the title might look quite generic
at the moment that's deliberate and when
you if you're obviously I heard you want
to be involved in your involved in the
task and finish group to be given to a
lot more granular level of detail of the
information that's there to be able to
come up with some recommendations and
options for the pharmacy on the
specifically relationship passing
symptoms
which is the next question I was going
to ask if I mean it's obviously the
Partington needs
um the children to come up to speak with
them before really and I think is it so
nice mentioned as well and it's still
fairly using High deprivation which that
makes the services
okay
if we just come up to that very
specifically so I think one of the
things that obviously we've touched on
is about access to access to Primary
Care and what that means and in regards
to like patient inpatient engagement
specifically
we are working with those very specific
areas of that have been reported back
both from the health and causes
information but also from that patient
feedback and what we're aiming to do or
not have started is working with those
practices individually but also working
most importantly with the patient groups
already associated with those practices
a well-established patient feedback
groups and say what does primary care
access look and feel like for you
there's no point in doing a review like
this that highlights very specific areas
within the soccer population if we're
not going to pinpoint those areas and
work with them on an individual basis
and that's very much Our intention as
part of this review
whilst we're doing this work life is
carrying on anywhere so there are
changes around things like Pharmacy
contracts GP contracts as well that we
need to take accounts of is since the
video started a lot of that to
progressed as well so actually some of
the work that we've identified as
concerns and we've been not only
mitigated before we even get to the end
of the review because
you know the NHS never stand this stuff
and a lot of those students
thank you
thank you cousin coming
thank you chair um I've come to them
that member of committee but um
and to start with we had some questions
from a man of the public which was
submitted to democratic Services I
understood sorry I think I wasn't we had
some questions from public submissions
through Democratic Services I understood
there were to be Delta at the beginning
of the decision I wonder if we should do
those first and then come back to mine
turn to the
Zoo so the questions I've had I was
copied in they're all about this items
typically
yes response okay
okay so that's obviously not the usual
procedure no no short procedures they're
not specific to this particular item no
exactly specific to the ultimate this is
what the customer finish review it will
be dealt with
okay all right well thank you
yeah thanks I was just going to say
anything we received the questions are
hard ones
so that's why
my response um so it's not that we're
gonna you're trying to avoid answers we
will provide a very just response
okay thanks she did I know submit them
on time according to the usual procedure
and everything so addressing procedure
if you've been given too much time so
she can't expect no it's not it doesn't
seem correct it's not the confuses it's
not in particular
okay okay but it was submission
um okay can I use a third of my
questions then uh with the assurances
she will get a detailed answer by email
um
so yes
um I've been watching um cancer
obviously very concerned about the minor
injuries unit and so the phase two of
your work
um described coming up with possible
models and which I thought we would have
in this document but then we've only got
priorities and and the priorities I I
see six of them are all about improving
developing reducing their array with
active growth the one they're looking at
is very different so considering
um so are there models out there that
aren't in this and I haven't seen 71
page document perhaps that was when we
said to remember the committee would be
great if I sort of preparances we could
see it as well and are there some
possible models that are for
consideration at the moment and that's
the first question
and secondly again perhaps this is in
the seven to one page document but the
minor injuries unit uh is identified as
a key area of comment and so 13 and but
again there's no info on on what those
really good to see them and just in
reference to some of the points made um
recently there about transport and
access of course it says ultimate is
identified in the document in one of the
areas with potential risk of um
transport related social exclusion so um
it's not a a uniform area where everyone
has access to a car and and so on so
that was the third Point
um
I think we just have to highlight as
well the fact that outside eight it
mentions that there is no extra funding
or resources for this so again really
this is an exercise in moving around
bonding within and then for businesses
and I think there's a risk of
um creating a positive customer between
meeting the needs of people in one area
and another when really we could be
meeting all of the needs if um if we had
to vote I know that's known in this room
we can fix that but I feel it's
important to notice it and I'll I'll
leave it with that for now
yeah so the models are the priorities
the models that we work with in those
privacy groups so there's no specific
preconceived models of what we're going
to do to go off with developments within
that within those variety areas and I'm
transport elements you know I take your
point but I think when we look at the
information
culturally is well versed from a
transport perspective and I think we
need to conscious that the other
alternative which is wooden short it's
three miles away
and as a crow flying so we just need to
be conscious that there's an urgent
treatment center that we've been sure
saying so that needs to play into
account within that and then from a
funding perspective so this isn't about
the company when we talk about ultimate
money in the Junior's unit because the
patients are still in the system and
still being seen still being seen by
somebody today so there is no savings at
all related to talking from our
perspectives and
we ensure that we're clear on that and
the envelope that we provide to MRT
covers all of those patients
I'm sure there's another question and
I'll probably missed
um the key area of comment uh can we get
some more info on what sort of comments
if I were there
and also the
quotes itself
is actually under
ground I've read that one is that was a
civilizing to new 71 pages
so we
worked with the end of the end of
October hopefully if we uh on the
timeline in terms of the full review
um but that is the existing
um
for the minor interviews you would have
to go through the line by line
the analysis so we can pull them out and
share them by all means that's not an
issue and
yeah that would be uh
there will be opportunity for being able
to improve into these yeah
okay
and just to be really clear in relation
to your clarification so in October we
will be imposing what the options are we
won't be coming back with a
um a Facebook company if you will so
this will literally be based on the
developments of review what that entails
these will be uh options based on what
the days are telling those feedback from
patients Etc so it won't be the end of
the review of that period at the end of
the phase of all the options have been
considered and we've come back with
recommendations based on the options
that are being proposed
if that makes sense it will be a final
decision or Divinity decision about the
future of ultra modeling place or
anything else in the interview it will
be a point in time which the review
comes to a natural conclusion where it
proposes options
those then be considered further verify
we might end up with documents saying
here are four different options and
we're recommending option two
that's essentially I mean I suppose the
point is it's not for us
enough so
um it will be for the world healthy
it's not for the sovereign
that is
what we will be doing is putting forward
recommendations based on the information
intelligence
that you've got within the use of
and these will be coming back yeah
um
is this taking into account the drop
nationally and recently of fruit monster
in GPS and the lack of new GPS coming
through to replace those retiring
the pressure's last couple calls on our
GP services
currently going through so
and obviously we work forced in the
ability to have an effective Workforce
is all part of the considerations that
we're discussing as part of the review
and obviously across Trafford we have a
significant Workforce agenda and that we
look at on a regular basis of all
elements that affects the ability to
deliver any of these services or any of
the proposed options within them
Workforce is intrinsic
abrasive is one of the key things we
look at and if we look at this
specifically in primary care which has
been highlighted we've got some issues
Workforce is the one that we're looking
up from the main initial and then
obviously see what we can do as part of
those recommendations and the options
about how we can work support towards
mitigating any of those potential and
Workforce gaps that it might have and it
might not just be GPS it could be
therapists it could be a nurse
practitioners yeah there's a whole Suite
of people and services that support
workers delivered
[Music]
and firstly I thought that it was a
really thorough piece of work that's
been undertaken there's been several
months and loads of people involved in
it
um
I think
um I was right in the show of you all
that the um whatever options are
delivered will be based on the data that
they have and also on the evidence of
Effectiveness and there was a comment
made earlier about a public involvement
in this and I have asked several uh
quite awkward questions as we've gone
along
um and I've generally had um
satisfactory answers so the sorts of
questions that I've asked have been
things like estate's utilization and to
make sure that we have the extra
buildings and that you know when they
perform used to that to write value for
the for the traffic
and I've asked about a pharmacy as well
and and particularly things like the
outer hours
um availability and when I was bashing
around and trying to hit some Asian
medication a few months ago to discover
there were only two pharmacies that
provided
um
and we also know that there have been
problems with medications and that's
been because there's been shortages uh
coming in from Europe and I had that
direct from uh the pharmacists
themselves we also question things about
Air transport about Workforce and
importantly about constitutional
standards because we have talked
throughout the whole of this evening
about the quality of services and if we
do not group institutions standards then
we'll provide employee care that is
required by all of our residents so a
lot of these questions have been asked
if there's any future involvement and
that we can
be a part of it we would be and happy to
do that as part of any
consultation and
as as James and Kathy have said no
decisions have been take and Murphy said
to me with them for option one two I
don't even know what the options are at
this stage and but I'm sure that I am at
the end of October and then we were out
there will be a lot clearer in the mind
but these are all the sorts of questions
that have been asked on behalf of the
public and throughout the world and and
as James McAfee said we were involved
originally
um analyzing the data that came back
from the consultation and again it was
just us preparing the reports which
presented the facts the evidence of
nothing else to support and so I just
wanted to make sure that
um this will probably be the foreign
about trying to and make sure that we do
provide that quality of service after
all of the
um
Scandal traders that it was over the
last few months it becomes all the more
important
as James said and it's never evolving
documents so we'll be looking at our
data on a regular basis because what
boxing which further paste now so we
know that urgent care and access to
urgent care services equally we would
believe and pre-pandemic levels now so
we've got something real to come as a
comparison to but in the original
documentation that came out in January
it we did have a pre-pandemic period as
well so we made sure it was reflective
of actual demand
[Music]
can we approve that
thank you excuse me am I okay yes
um if you like to say something
um
foreign
[Music]
Ty
to talk about
[Music]
um
so I'm not quite sure I mean I've been
on the panel before making a bachelor
I've been on my panel for healthcare
together I've been on the panel for
healthier together part two I'm now
heavily involved in
aging matter and I talked to Public
Health but Trafford almost every day
so I'm just wondering why
I don't know anything about this and why
I am constantly contacted by staff
Journal who are really really
democratized they tell me that one more
time is still directing people to
manually start every day that has really
anxious and angry people who have been
sent over necessarily we know in the
short period of time that my injuries
reopened but wasn't sure we're actually
taxing the people down
[Music]
is anybody here tonight have they ever
tried to get to factor General by public
transport as they were trying to get to
Weddington like other times
it's not easy and one of the ideas that
I won't ever involved in often that was
building we were asked quite properly
what would be good to have locally and
we said actually because people going to
Manchester campus or routine exams that
they didn't need to and that happened
which
[Music]
has now hopefully got an HS property
actually getting people in
um I just think that really you can say
to who has written that you've done a
really good job of my point of view
definitely in half and we've had two
meetings with senior people have two we
know that nft don't like the hospital
they don't like the building they don't
want it to be there
building
and they're just a solicitors are just
looking at taking the last they tender
away so that possibly they're concerned
I don't know whether this is used to you
but I've seen it
yeah
I'm about to respond to that
yeah please suggestions here at the last
point now I'm not aware of that and the
communication we've had with MFC today
and yesterday was about what's going
through the hospital no further plans to
make any change
yeah
and hopefully now they'll have some
well-being centers got NHS property
actually trying to let there was going
to be a pharmacy there isn't Pharmacy uh
hopefully we've got the Dental training
center on the hospital I know we've got
some District nurses we've got some
Council offices and that's right but it
has taken a very long time and I think
um I work for prosperous Manchester
United with aging well I've also worked
expensively in the past with Joshua is
in Chester West you'll have exactly the
same problem with good learning choice
um you make it so that people don't know
whether it's open or not something I
said there's no need for it
um
I think that there should be a lot more
publicity about planning your diagnostic
services at Worthington because that is
Dreadful to get to it's Dreadful by
public transport and it's also not very
good driving because it gets into
traffic jams I have somebody and family
and I don't know my health watch haven't
approached it but it's a mystery but I
mean I want to thank health school to
you because I was here all through last
year
but just like to say to the new ones but
I'm really worried about that I mean old
Freeman Hospital was deemed unsuitable
to be there in 1926 we finally got a new
hospital after going to the high court
and now it's as if there wasn't any
point
um I know that at least one Mandarin
scrutiny Community feels that Ultra
young is too privileged and entitled to
have a hospital
um yesterday I asked for the daily term
of which Wards have the most other
people
um School awards in the sand for all the
money I know the people has been spent
in the northwest
so none of it makes any sense to me
thank you Chad
thank you
yeah
I think it would be really helpful if we
take it away from here today and sit
down with you and try and understand
some of those issues that you've got and
it may be that you know that we can
bring those those resolutions back to
health scrutiny but you know as far as
I'm aware
and alternative impossible's going
nowhere you know it's staying wherever
it is I sat for there and through my
union and Unison I know lots of stuff
that stuff are talking around and you
know and I know that reps that are in
the hospital are reassuring people
because that is the message that it's
not closing so we do need to keep that
message that the hospital's not closing
and what's going to happen is there's
going to be the review of where we're up
to with the Urgent Care school and it
might be that as part of that process
the money is there to be able to if we
open that maybe change it into an urgent
care center as as Kathy said earlier but
we don't know what that is but I just
think it'd be helpful chair if we take
those issues away and we meet the duty
separately to understand some of those
things well thank you appreciate that
thank you
[Music]
I do seven is the one that's been
deferred enough for the next week
my recommendation was around section
seven in the minutes which
needs to be just that I haven't got any
comments on the GPS
you look back here
but if we went for our colleagues to uh
to really of course water
[Music]
[Applause]
try the next item is for the committee
to review the obviously the report that
was submitted from last year and to
agree the recommendations
and then we can move forward with this
report
so has anybody
have been received before
yeah
access to Europeans and I'm just looking
at the counselors who were on it
and I think I'm the only one here and
um
so
um we've made those recommendations and
yeah
look
we really want to be able to improve
that before that
this book is
I think that's what we're doing isn't it
that is why the committee is asked to do
but it does require a majority of
approval not just the member that was it
lasts too so if members are not had a
chance to consider the report then
perhaps they might need some more time
[Music]
thank you
committee and um you know it's nice to
have the conclusion to a classical
and I would like this you know sometimes
in the The Challenge because you've got
a lot of them together
okay
I promise you
I think it's a good healthy
social prescribing event
ually
now it's actually used to do community
group service
help and support
people in needs or isolation these are
the things that look
people couldn't get back in life so
yeah
Francis
great
all the organizations that he could in
terms of you know to attractive data
perhaps or I think it was very wrong
[Music]
so yes sorry Joe just to say that yes I
make contact with some groups and been
invited at the next meeting
um they haven't confirmed yet so as soon
as we know for sure then the meetings
will be finalized and then the task and
finish group can continue the
conversation but also to ex to remind
members that if you want to join the
group you are more than welcome because
at the moment there's only five member
so if there's anybody who's got anything
that they want to contribute they're
more than welcome to join uh
provisionally the next meeting will be
the 5th of October and it can be online
if it helps
[Music]
um
I apologize something that you convene
the meeting and then I realized that I
missed it so apologize chair for that
yeah
[Music]
on the Tuesday it can be 6 6 30 and
Twitter for confirmation from extended
numbers
it it's just a little bit challenging
for ourselves in the labor group it's
just because we do have another meeting
and scheduled at seven o'clock and to
get well I'm speaking myself and be
really quite difficult to get in for six
o'clock I think that's fine
is there any scope I mean I know we've
all got a really busy lives of multiple
demands
you know dictate the schedule on my time
but does it does it happen yeah I I
couldn't do it I mean I had three
meetings on that night so I spend half
an hour in French
I mean I don't know it's not a way yeah
majority they cannot make if nobody can
make it and obviously we'll find the new
days where everybody can make it but it
will be really difficult to yeah
opportunity everybody because everyone
this Diaries
yeah yeah obviously
how many people actually struggle to get
to a meeting before obviously I could
not get to me because
all the days of the week you know
that's just my situation everybody else
has got their own information
[Music]
around me that's all I'm saying there's
all the people who can make very
valuable contributions yeah
yeah
laughs
thank you
yeah right yes just please look for a
day after six o'clock
[Music]
how to screen the committee before
um
thank you
we have a great program but as you know
it's a recurrent item because things
will change throughout the year and also
next time there will be another Edition
that perhaps members are not aware yet
um so there were some questions last
time from the AIDS and adaptation before
the generated from that report and Mr
spearing has provided the responses but
um
because he couldn't be here tonight and
there was not enough time to work
um just provide the full response it
will go to November so in November you
will have a full update
as well
I mind how stupid
no energy business
I just wanted to actually mention that
if everybody received the letter which I
was sent from the
chief executive department
they've given us a assurance that it's
everything is okay and
how much information
[Music]
foreign
GPS
[Music]
and
yeah
um they went through so 300 gp's of the
office posts at the three services that
I'm taking foreign
the other three surgeries
are absorbing the 5000 and at the end of
October any of those patients that could
be updated for those three surgeons two
of which are interested yeah yeah and
the other is literally a short walk down
in the village so
yes there are problems with that if we
have communications about Royal Mail
areas of symptoms that's quite a good
experience and it's it's worked out okay
but
um it seems it seems like it's in hand
is it yeah
notification
and
that was you know Blaster information
that went down
um that shouldn't have and
it was dealt with over that weekend
and since then we came in with lots of
residents
that I wanted to know where they're
going what they're doing
um because they're not receive these
classes it's mainly those businesses
um you are just going to get the
allocated either to the Village surgery
please or the park and for the most part
A lot of them are okay with that they're
not terrified by the thought and
wouldn't do sex to them October
people ask them
that's the catchment area goes right
away to home runs which is
what people on the edge
that tries to order to reality into an
uncertainty and be rejected because 37
you want a horse
and we're like
um
[Music]
driving some flexibility to those that
don't miss out on
foreign
[Music]
this process to deal with this um
that process has been triggered and
followed and there are
but there are some problems with that in
terms of people getting the letters but
that's the process that
that is in place and I think
I think this committee can rightly
scrutinize that process in light of
what's happening at the growth practice
but I think
you know in a way it's regrettable that
that process wasn't allowed to follow
its cause you know and there were uh you
know Council of Quarry says a lot of
information was released into the public
around too early in appear in the Press
when Nations have an opportunity to
receive those letters so
um
so I do think a legitimate think of this
committed to look out would be
because this one the last practice this
happens to
um against the forest talks about you
know deep means leaving
um early and not being replaced so it
won't basically happen again and so
maybe that's something for the
commission to look at around this
process around hope missions are
reallocated and
um and following that process so that
patients are getting the information
rather than getting
information on social media
I think it's the case in Illinois
[Applause]
personally speaking of a very NBC I
haven't seen much
else you know the rotation because it
simply the surgeries are quite large
experience yeah
that
give that letters
or they're dispersed into those areas
they have to stay there for a specific
period of time so that they're not all
going over and asking in the same doctor
for them to come over there it has to be
it has to be able to stabilize it and
it was you know
the ones in court cells were absolutely
massive you know people got moved from
both Hill right out to uh toward traffic
didn't it you know it was a big it was a
big move it wasn't much around the
corner
they've done a good piece of work
to actually make sure that free
surgeries
and they're not far from our way I mean
[Music]
we received the email telling us about
this at
um ten past four
bank holiday weekend on a Friday
and and then it was blasted out on
social media within two hours now
it comes to the science room
um and that leftovers the entire weekend
having to firefight and having to
explain
I mean I think it's very unfortunate
that what happens I think that you know
the council has responded around what
happened around that but those patients
that have been going to that surgery are
known for the whole time that Del Mar
has been managing it that something is
going to have to give because they
couldn't get a replacement for Dr Shah
which is really unfortunate
but we know that you know 13 years or 70
no not creating new doctors not doing
whatever we needed to do has an impact
doesn't it it has to give yes it was it
was really unfortunate I think the
apology has been given by the council
and you know so bought those those
patients at that surgery I don't know if
you are one of them they did know for
some time that the doctor was retiring
or the doctor had retired yeah
[Music]
I mean how much notice was given
well the doctor only retired again
sufficient notice
um
couldn't get anybody else to come in and
do the work I think that's what's up
you know so
as I said I mean yeah
of saying they knew these retired but
because the service was considered
they didn't question it and so everyone
is supposed to be there is
the end of the street
so that was my fault really because I I
just sprayed
okay so uh of course there's no question
thank you thank you for your attendance
tonight
and then
stay tuned
foreign
[Music]